la vista a donde quiera que va el papa
ahí están junto a él son los guardias
suizos custodios del sumo pontífice
vestidos en civil o con sus pintorescos
uniformes garantizan la seguridad del
jefe de la Iglesia Católica en cualquier
situación
no es fácil ser guardaespaldas del Papa
Francisco es alguien muy sociable le
gusta el contacto con la gente las
multitudes hacemos preparación
mentalista y psicológica observamos los
comportamientos de la gente para
anticipar las potenciales situaciones de
peligro
esta tarde en el cuartel de los guardias
suizos situado en el corazón del
Vaticano un grupo de jóvenes soldados se
prepara para el entrenamiento Danilo
tiene 22 años y es uno de los 124
miembros del ejército más pequeño del
mundo
antes del entrenamiento tenemos que
pulir bien las corazas quitarles todas
las manchas de grasa que se van
impregnando en el Metal
terminada la preparación inicia el
entrenamiento
la guardia Suiza pontificia nació en
1506 cuando el papa Julio II pidió a
Suiza soldados para su protección y
formó una compañía de 150 hombres
hoy en día este ejército sigue atrayendo
a jóvenes reclutas como Álex uno de los
23 nuevos soldados que han Jurado
fidelidad al papa este año
decide ingresar en la guardia Suiza no
solo porque es una experiencia muy
interesante a nivel profesional en el
sector de la seguridad pero también
porque lo veo como una ocasión de
profundizar mi fe
para entrar en este ejército Hay que ser
ciudadanos suizo católico practicante
soltero tener entre 19 y 30 años una
reputación impecable y mucho empeño y
pues se necesita voluntad y mucha
tenacidad porque al inicio no es nada
fácil
los reclutas se comprometen a prestar
servicio por al menos 26 meses
protegiendo al papa y perpetuando la
tradición del ejército más antiguo del
mundo